>>Female Presenter: I am incredibly happy
to wrap up Privacy Week with our final glory.
We've got the author Jeff Jarvis here to give
us a talk about his most recent book, which
is called "Public Parts," which covers and
stands up for the value of information and
the value of sharing it in a digital world.
So, within the set of people who talk about
and argue about privacy publicly, there are
a whole lot of people out there talking about
the importance of being very careful not to
share when you don't want to, being very careful
to have spaces that are not public, having
things that are secret.
And Jeff's voice is a really important counterbalance
to speak up for the importance in a healthy
society of actually talking to each other,
of actually having things to say, as he would
say, "of sharing."
And as someone who has loomed large on the
Google landscape ever since his previous book,
"What Would Google Do?" it's really, really
great to have him in this conversation with
us.
And I expect he's gonna have a lot of stimulating
things to say to us today.
Thanks so much, Jeff.
>>Jeff Jarvis: Thank you.
[applause]
Did any of you attend the last talk I gave
here which was on privacy?
OK.
Some of you.
'Cause I promised this is Part Two, but I'll
go through a quick spiel of Part One is because
actually I wanna talk more about publicness
than privacy 'cause I was brought here before
to do a privacy event.
Let me go through pretty quickly where that
goes.
And yes, by the way, I am the most certified
Google fan boy there is having written a book
telling the world to think like you.
I also was very happy the first time I came
here to give a book talk on that book.
My fear was I was now in the room with rocket
scientists who could tell me just how full
of shit I was.
But you're all too polite to have done so.
So, I'm grateful for that.
So, this time I wanted to write about publicness,
but to get there, I had to get through privacy.
And privacy and publicness are not binary.
They don't fight with each other.
Yeah?
>>MALE #1: Is this event private, or are we
allowed to post publicly?
>>Jeff Jarvis: My life is an open blog.
I have no secrets.
>>Female Presenter: It's gonna be posted on
YouTube.
>>Jeff Jarvis: It's gonna be posted on YouTube,
too.
Yeah, I know.
Post away.
Please.
I love it.
@jeffjarvis.
Twitter.
[laughter]
Jeff Jarvis on Google+, BuzzMachine.
Facebook slash Jeff Jarvis.
I'm delighted.
Now, we'll get to talk about over-sharing
in a second, but--self-promotion.
[laughter]
So, history.
Privacy and publicness are like hot and cold,
like wet and dry--this continuum.
It's not either or.
I think that's very, very important.
But I tried to look at privacy.
And again, I'm gonna rush through this part.
But a little bit of the history of privacy,
which I mentioned last time, is that I didn't
realize that the first serious legal discussion
about privacy, or legal right to privacy,
did not come in the US until 1890 with the
invention of a technology--the Kodak camera--tied
to the rise of the penny press, freaked people
out because something like, "My God.
My picture could be anywhere."
And Teddy Roosevelt banned "Kodaking" as it
was called in Washington parks briefly because
he didn't want pictures taken of him or his
family.
And look how we've changed as a society and
how our norms have changed around "please
take a picture of me," everywhere except Germany.
[laughter]
And so, what we're going through now is changes
of norms around this.
A fairly obvious thing, but in the earliest
villages, of course, there was very little
privacy.
We walked to each other's huts.
And the first homes we did was an invention
of the hall, the invention of the back stairs
that led to a society that started to have
expectations of privacy.
Those were technologies in their way, in their
time.
And it's said that privacy was invented in
England of that time.
So privacy hasn't been around forever.
I struggled a lot with the definitions of
privacy.
And it turns out to be very, very, very difficult,
I found, to get to a definition because it's
an empty vessel word.
As even some of the people who study privacy
and know it well, say it means everything
and nothing.
Brandeis and Warren who wrote that 1890 law
essay about privacy that really led to bringing
privacy into American law, said that it gets
down to the right to be let alone.
And what they really said is that it's about
feelings.
And so, when we try and talk about the harm
based on privacy it becomes very difficult
because it really is about feelings.
It's about your fear of what someone else
might think of you that they may never say.
In fact, they may not think it.
So that's what's so insidious about it.
You're imagining, you're fearing, what they
might think.
And that that becomes a lot of the essence
of the emotions around privacy.
Other things like identity theft and fraud
and those kinds of things and stalking, I
think are separate crimes.
I think part of the problem with privacy is
we throw a lot into that bucket.
But privacy itself, even Brandeis and Warren
say, it has a basis in emotion.
So, that's all I wanna say about privacy,
believe it or not, in Privacy Week.
I didn't know it was a whole week.
I should be here all week.
So, but of course it's private, so no one
knew about it.
[laughter]
So I'm happy to talk any bit more you want
about privacy.
Actually, one more thing.
So, I come to finally, if I can't define it
very well, I come to view privacy as an ethic--an
ethic of knowing.
And so, the idea here is that if I tell Chris
something quietly, then it is public to that
extent.
Right?
Same as circles.
You tell one person, it's public to that extent.
So, at that point then, the responsibility
for what to do with that information lies
on Chris's shoulders.
And he has to make a whole series of judgments
as to, "Well, did I think--.
Jarvis, what's the context?
Was it said to me in private?
Is it harmful to him if I spread that around?
Do I not like him and I want to spread it
around as a result?
Do I have a responsibility as a company to
keep this data secure?"
And so on and so on.
And so, the ethics that you go through in
your list, really, are somewhat mirrored to
the ethics that I try to deal with there.
Don't steal information, people.
Don't fool them out of it.
Keep it secure.
Give them access to it--to their own information.
Make it portable--deliberation front.
And so on.
So, I have a list of those.
The complementary ethic is an ethic of publicness.
Now, we get to publicness.
And the idea there is that it's an ethic of
sharing.
That it says that if I know something that
could be helpful to someone else, then I'm
gonna make a decision as to whether or not
to share that.
And I'm not arguing that everything should
be public, everything should be out there,
that all of life is transparent.
I go through a list of things in my book of
the things that I don't really wanna share.
I don't really wanna share income.
Now in Scandinavia, they share income and
taxes.
But here, we don't and I don't know why I
don't want to, but I don't.
But then I go along and say, "But I'm a teacher
at a public university with a contract."
So you find out what I make.
In fact, today on my blog, somebody I won't
mention eviscerated me yesterday.
And I'm not gonna give him any freaking credit.
[laughter]
I said that on YouTube.
So, he tried to say that I was hypocritical
because I was not willing to say my income.
Well, no.
I was just explaining my emotions.
And indeed, I did then say my income--pathetic
as it is--as a university professor.
And some of the comments on my blog today
came in and pointed to a site I didn't know
existed that has my income up there on the
site.
But that's fine 'cause I'm public.
So, an ethic of sharing.
I was at the World Trade Center on 9/11.
I wrote about that in my last book.
Since then, I've gotten prostate cancer, thyroid
cancer, and a heart condition.
[chuckles wryly] Now you know everything you
wanna know about me and more.
Now, the fact that that happened publicly
wasn't correlated to 9/11, but what if it
were?
That data point, those three data points,
are of value potentially to other people who
were there.
So, I can choose to share them or choose not
to share them.
I can choose to share them with a circle or
with the world, right?
But to choose not to do so, I think at some
point in society, we could see that as selfish,
as antisocial.
And that gets me in trouble.
But I think we've got to get to a society
where it is possible to do that.
So, why wouldn't I share health?
Well, let's talk about the notion of radically
sharing health.
And this came out--.
I gave a talk at the Google headquarters in
New York and somebody from the Health Team
was there.
So, this is what actually inspired this.
What if we shared every bit of our health
data?
Why don't we?
Well, one reason is we may not get a job.
But that's society's problem.
That's a legal issue about the use of the
data that says that if you discriminate at
me because I have a sickness, we can declare
that illegal.
I may not get insurance.
And even if that is private data, the insurance
company can get all my medical records, so
it's really not that private as far as they're
concerned.
The other reason is stigma.
We have a stigma in society about certain
illnesses.
And that's why when I talked about my prostate
cancer and my malfunctioning penis, I did
it for a reason in the book because it tries
to get past that stigma.
I also got incredible benefit back for it.
People gave me advice that I would never have
gotten because they knew publicly that I--.
I had friends that had the operation ten years
before.
I didn't know they'd had it.
Because I was public, they knew I was going
to have it.
They came to me and gave me great advice.
Finally, we, as a group, tried to inspire
other men to get tested for PSA.
And most of you are too young for this, but
no matter what the government said last week,
I still say get your PSA tested because more
information is always better than less information.
And surely, that's something you believe here
at Google.
Anyway, so there are benefits to publicness
and benefits to sharing, benefits to society
and generosity, benefits to the individual.
So, I try to list those benefits in the book.
And part of my reason I'm doing so, is I think
it's important for the likes of Google and
Facebook and Twitter, to start to sell the
benefits of publicness because the conversation
is all about privacy, all about what could
go wrong.
And if we managed life all to the worst case,
we'll never discover the best case and this
is the valley of the best case.
I'm accused all the time of being an internet
Utopian Here's utopia, right?
[laughter]
And it feels so good.
And it's true.
It's true what they say about Heaven.
You get all the food you can eat.
[laughter]
So, sorry.
That just threw me off.
[laughter]
Where was I?
So, the benefits.
We've got to sell the benefits of this because
the conversation is only the worst case, only
what could go wrong, only the fear.
Then, that's what rules so much of what you
do.
And not in a marketing way, but in a real
way, we've got to try to go shift the conversation
to the benefits of publicness, to the good
things that happen when people can connect,
to each other and information and actions
and so on.
So, I list a bunch of benefits.
They're the ones I list, but it's about making
relationships.
It's about the notion of killing the idea
of stranger.
I've made so many friends.
I've met so many people who are now no longer
strangers.
It's the idea of killing or disarming of these
stigmas.
I argue in the book that publicness was the
best weapon that gays and lesbians in this
country had to force back the bigots who had
forced them into the closet.
And I do not suggest for one second that anyone
should be forced out of, or dragged out of,
that closet.
But those who had the courage to do so stood
up to the bigots and said, "OK.
OK.
So, we're gay.
You got a problem with that?"
It's what we would say in New Jersey.
And that's a very, very powerful force.
Publicness brings the potential for collaboration.
Publicness allows us to collect the wisdom
of the crowd.
Publicness, I think, starts to fight down
the myth of perfection, which we have from
the Industrial Age--that everything we make
is perfect, that everything we do is perfect.
Well, you guys fight that down with the beta.
And that's a huge, I think, gift to society
is the example that you can put something
out and if you put it out and it's not done,
that it's necessarily a call for collaboration.
It is in my view, the beta is a very important
sign of humanity and humility, even from God
Google.
And that is because you are public with the
process of what you do.
Publicness gives credit.
I try to argue, even immortality.
If you're not public, then no one will remember
you afterwards.
And finally, it allows us to organize ourselves.
I get to say in front of the God of the hash
tag that we're witnessing something amazing
in Occupy Wall Street--a revolution based
on a hash tag.
Part of my theory, by the way, that I started
to play with a little bit in the book, but
keep playing with it since, is that I see
more and more life coming to imitate and mimic
the architecture of the net.
And this is an example where it's happening.
This is a case where people are confused as
hell about Occupy Wall Street because they
say, "Where's the structure?
Where's the organization?
Who's the leader?
What are the goals?"
No one owns a hash tag.
There is no organization.
There is no structure.
There is no hierarchy.
There is no creed.
It's an idea that people put something into.
I think it was after I was here last time.
I violated one of the rules of my book, which
is the Cabernet rule.
Never to --. Don't allow friends to tweet,
blog, Google+ or anything after too much wine.
Well, it wasn't Cabernet.
It was Pinot Noir.
But I was really pissed off in the midst of
the so-called negotiations over the debt and
I went and sat down and I said, "Fuck you,
Washington."
Ooh.
"It's our money.
It's our economy.
You're messing with it."
And then I joked and I said, "You know?
We should have a chant on Twitter."
And then somebody came in and said--for all
I know, it may have been Chris under a different
identity--"You idiot.
That's called a hash tag."
And so, I said, "Right.
Fuck you, Washington."
And people got mad at me, some did, for not
making it F you, Congress or F you this person
or that person.
But what fascinated me about this was people
filled in the rest of the sentence when they
used the hash tag.
"F you Washington because my parents don't
know if they can pay the bills next month."
"F you Washington because you won't let me
marry who I want to."
'F you Washington because you idiots can't
negotiate like a three-year old."
And it was a blank slate.
Well, similarly I think, Occupy Wall Street
is a bit of a blank slate and people are putting
upon it their beliefs and their frustrations.
And now, we're seeing a process of discernment
in public to bring out "Why are you occupying
Wall Street?
What do you want?
What are you pissed about?"
And we're starting to hear it.
The media can't figure this out.
But the people who are there can.
So, organizing us.
Another way that I think I see the internet
structure coming into society is news.
That in Tahrir Square, we saw--.
People didn't--.
Andy Carvin at NPR didn't say to the New York
Times, didn't say to the people in Tahrir
Square, "Hey, why don't you crowd-source your
revolution?
Send your pictures to CNN and you could be
a field reporter for us."
No.
They used these tools for the revolution.
They used the tools for what they wanted and
we could watch because they did it in public.
And so what you saw there was the architecture
of the net end to end, witness to world, brought
to life.
And I find that fascinating that because it
was in public that was happening.
Andy Carvin at NPR, I'm sure you all know,
sat at a distance and added value to that--added
journalistic value to that.
Who is really there?
Who's not there?
Debunking rumors, confirming things and so
on and so forth.
But that notion of the architecture happening
in public.
Well, what part of this goes to, too, is the
notion, the question of what is a public?
What is the public?
So I dared to go into Habermas a bit in the
book.
I didn't study Habermas in school.
I'm an amateur at Habermas, I will confess.
I found him rather indigestible.
[laughter]
But those of you who studied--.
How many of you had to study Habermas?
OK.
Thank you.
Right.
So, by the way, somebody, this person who
eviscerated me, who I'm not gonna mention,
took me to task because I mentioned Habermas
and Oprah Winfrey in the same book.
That's how holy he is.
But he's very important because he defines
the terms of the conversation about the notion
of the public sphere.
Habermas argues that it was not until the
18th Century that we had, in the form of rational
and critical debate in salons and cafés,
the formation of a public sphere that was,
for the first time, a force counterweight
to government--to the King.
And I think he's right.
I think it was important.
I don't know if the discussion was necessarily
so rational and critical then, but he then
argues that it was corrupted by mass media
coming in and changing the tenor of that.
Well, then I came across some researchers
out of McGill, who did a wonderful project
on the making of the modern public.
And they finally decided that there were the
tools to make public before the 18th Century.
That when three thousand people gathered in
the Globe Theater to watch Richard the Third--it
is Richard the Third who's the bad King?
You're a smart crowd, or was the Second?
>>FEMALE #1: Third.
>>Jeff Jarvis: Third?
OK.
Thank you.
Got that.
See, I'm not an academic.
Richard the Third--.
A public is formed around the idea of what
do we do when we have an incompetent ruler?
So the stage, the book of course, maps, art,
markets, printed sermons--all these things
were tools in the early modern period, the
early Renaissance, for making publics.
And so, what I think starts to happen here
is we come back around now and we see that
this corruption of the public sphere that
Habermas laments, and I agree with him on
this, we now have the opportunity to turn
this around today because we, you create the
tools that enable people to create their own
publics.
I was on Twitter today and I forget what brought
it up, but I said something about media, or
I think it was Clay Shirky.
By the way, there's a law that says all the
internet optimists must quote Clay Shirky
once a day, so I'm about to fulfill my legal
obligation.
And Clay was talking about media and somebody
said in Twitter, "Maybe we should have Occupy
Media."
And I said, "We've already done that.
That's what this is.
You're in the midst of it, right?"
So, we have these tools to create publics.
And indeed, I think that Habermas's idea of
'the public sphere' was a bastardization of
the notion of many publics.
And he knows that and there are debates about
that as well.
But, I think what we have now is the power
to create many, many publics.
And that's what you do.
You give people the ability to gather together
around an idea, an event, a need, a thought,
a joke, anything.
You and these other tools enable us.
Search enables it and so on.
So, what happens to media in this world?
Well, it used to be that there was only one
way to get to content--one means of discovery
and distribution.
Brands.
You had to buy the newspaper or the magazine,
the book, watch the TV show, whatever.
Then, along came Search.
You turned it around so that now people who
asked the question could start the process.
And if you had an answer, great.
If you didn't, you weren't there.
You didn't live.
But now there is, I believe, the next layer
of this is sharing as a means of content discovery
and distribution.
And that's what Zuckerberg wants.
That's why he has Wall Street Journal and
Washington Post and The Guardian on Facebook.
That's what you want, I think, with Google+.
The more we can add signal.
So, I argue that the Senate was way wrong
when they brought your executive chairman
to the carpet on the basis of controlling
search.
That was yesterday's war.
I think the current war is signal gen--.
Bless you.
Is signal generation.
And I'm telling you your business.
But what I see from afar is that you, through
Google+, certainly through Android, and through
other means, and Facebook and others, are
trying to get people to generate signals about
themselves so that you can better serve them
more relevant content and services, and yes,
advertising.
And so, signal generation becomes very important.
It's who we are, where we are, who do we know,
what do we like, what do we like, what do
we buy, what don't we like, where are we going,
where have we been, what sort of behavior.
All of these things are, of course, signals.
But of course, that starts to freak people
out because it goes into privacy.
And part of what we have to do, I think, is
do a better job of selling the idea to people
that there is value to this.
And we don't do that by telling them that
there's value to this.
We do that, I think, by showing them.
Because you get this, you get that.
So, I get people all the time who'll ask me
about cookies.
We've demonized cookies.
We've demonized this notion of tracking.
And that's partly the fault of us in this
industry.
And I include in that media and advertising
because we didn't explain to people what we
were doing, why we were doing it, what they
were getting out of it.
And they discovered it after the fact.
And they got freaked.
And maybe they should have.
But I tell them all the time, you can go into
Chrome--a wonderful browser--and you can have
the incognito window.
And you can cut off all your cookies.
Your experience is going to be that you get
dancing monkey heads again and again and again.
And there's an ethical question there that
you've now devalued yourself as a user with
those media sites who were giving you stuff
for free.
And if enough people do that, if we have "do
not track" legislation, the ultimate unintended
consequence of that could be, I believe, content
dying or content going behind walls.
Which is not good for us at all.
So, there's a reason to try to sell this.
And I hope that you do that.
So, out of media to a few more thoughts.
And then I really wanna have a conversation,
'cause every time I talk to Googlers, I get
a headache 'cause you have such great thoughts
and I wanna get to that.
'Cause it helps me.
Over-sharing.
I was accused by one person of over-sharing
because I wrote about my penis in public.
And oddly, this guy--he didn't like me anyway--there
are people like that out there.
The price of publicness is you get the haters.
And this guy never liked me.
Oddly, he also had prostate cancer.
But said I was over-sharing.
Well, it's an odd concept, over-sharing, because
what he's really doing is telling me to shut-up.
Right?
He's telling me, "Don't share this."
Well, the beauty of the architecture we have
on the net today is there's a very easy answer
to that.
Unfollow me.
Defriend me.
Uncircle me.
Don't click on me.
There's all these ways that you don't have
to hear what I have to say.
For you to tell me what I can or cannot say--F
you.
The problem here is not over-sharing.
The problem here is his over listening, right?
[laughter]
He's hearing too much.
Now, is there such a thing as over-sharing,
then?
I think over-sharing is sharing that which
you regret having shared.
And we've all gone through that.
We've all had to learn.
We do need to educate people.
Danah Boyd, I'm sure you all know of Danah
Boyd, researcher at Microsoft Labs and now
NYU.
Brilliant.
Wonderful, Danah Boyd.
Taught me so much about this.
And says that we overprotect our children
actually, that we need to have them out interacting
with the world.
And that the problem here is not the gathering
of data, but the use of data.
So, if I
walk into your office and I apply for a job,
you can see in a glance that I have prematurely
grey hair.
[laughter]
That my gender, my race, probably my education,
where I'm from and so on.
Certain of that information, you may not use
to hire me or not hire me.
However, you can still do it.
You can still say, "I'm not gonna hire that
old fart."
And nothing's gonna stop you.
However, if you do it again and again and
again and again, there's a pattern there.
But we cannot make you forget that I have
prematurely grey hair.
It's impossible.
Yet, what we're trying to do now is talk about
a right of forgetting.
We're trying to manage the gathering of information
and that's a dangerous thing to do because
when you do that, you cut off flows of information.
And you also potentially, in this notion of
the right to forget by the way, impinge on
someone else's freedom of speech.
If I write about you and you complain and
there are laws that you make me take this
down, you've now impinged upon my free speech
to say what I think of you for not hiring
me because I have prematurely grey hair.
So, we have to be careful of where we go with
these unintended consequences.
I just wrote an op ed about COPPA, the Children's
Online Privacy Protection Act, that decrees
that a site may not know basically anything
specific about a child under 13, like what
town you're in--anything.
So, if you wanna do a geography game and have
people start from their home, you can't do
it unless you have the explicit permission
of the parent.
And under the newly revised regulations, the
parent can't even respond by email.
The parent has to print out, fax, or--fax,
remember that?
Fax or scan the document, or get on a video
conference with the employee of the company.
So, clearly no one does.
So I was on a call--.
With the Future of Privacy Forum, I was on
a call with the attorney, the attorney on
this at the FDC and I asked a couple questions
about what I saw as the unintended consequences
of COPPA.
One, on the internet, no one knows you're
a dog and everyone is 14.
We are teaching children to lie about their
age, right?
No one is under 13.
Number two, I said, "Do you have any data
about how much truth you get about age?"
None.
Second question, "How much do parents avail
themselves of these means of notice and consent?"
No data.
Three.
Most important thing in my mind is that the
unintended consequence here is that children
are the worst served demographic online by
far.
I started a site.
The second site I started to learn the web
back in '95--all my children--was the yuckiest
site on the internet about cockroaches and
goo with the Liberty Science Center in New
Jersey.
And it was a lot of fun.
We sold it to Discover.
It's still around.
You can learn about your snot.
[laughter]
And after we sold it, my employers said, "We're
not doing that again with COPPA because the
risk is too great."
So, the unintended consequence here is that
we underserve children because we try to negotiate
the wrong thing.
Other unintended consequences.
Australia is looking to put in filters up
on all content on the net just to get to porn--child
porn.
Well, child porn's a banned thing, but they've
created an architecture in that case.
It can be used in Iran.
It can be used in China, used by despots.
And we shouldn't allow that to happen to our
net, but that's where this privacy talk goes
if it goes too far.
I'm trying to--.
Let me talk for a moment about identity because
it's a hot topic and I think it's a fascinating
topic.
So, a lot of talk these days about the real
name fight you started, you, Google, started
because of Google+, and whose fault is it?
Who did it?
I think I know, actually.
[chuckles]
A little birdie told me.
And here's the way I talk about it with people.
Let me try it this way.
I believe that they key insight that Facebook
and Zuckerberg had was real people, real relationships.
And that that did, in fact, add value to the
discourse and the quality of discourse on
the net.
It's not the cure-all to trolls and bozos.
There are many trolls and bozos, I know by
name.
So, identity alone doesn't solve that problem,
but identity does bring up the investment
people have in this.
So, I think that it's beneficial.
There is still an absolute and permanent need
for anonymity and pseudonymity.
It is part of free speech.
It is part of enabling the vulnerable whistle-blowers,
dissidents and tyrannies to be able to speak.
So, I will defend anonymity.
I will defend pseudonymity and nicknames for
various reasons.
But I do think that identity is a good thing.
I think candidly, Google+ went a little too
far in trying to say that only a real name
is a guarantee of being a real person.
And you also put yourself in a bad bind because
you became the arbiters of that at Google+
versus at Facebook, it's really the community
that's more the arbiter of it.
The bloodstream rejects fake beings.
And the bloodstream here doesn't do that.
So, I suspect you--.
I know you'll come around and--.
[telephone rings]
Is that me?
>>Female Presenter: Hello?
>>Jeff Jarvis: No, it's me.
>>Female Presenter: It's you.
It's you.
>>Jeff Jarvis: Yeah, I thought I turned it
off.
[laughter]
>>Female Presenter: Of all people to not have
it off.
>>Jeff Jarvis: It is.
It is.
Oh no.
I have to take this.
No, I don't.
[laughter]
>>Female Presenter: You can only do that once.
>>Jeff Jarvis: Now you see I ripped my jacket.
>>Female Presenter: We've had that before,
by the way.
Rooms calling here.
It's happened.
>>Jeff Jarvis: That would be fun.
I'd rather have a conversation with somebody.
I'd like that.
All right.
Identity.
So, I think that went too far.
I understand why it was there.
I think you've gotta find more subtlety and
nuance in this.
But I also understand that there's great value
to having anonymity online and to have a verified
identity online.
I mean, I'm a fan of Howard Stern.
And when Biz Stone went to visit Howard one
time, the office crew had a fight over--.
Howard decided to make a game out of it and
tortured them.
And so, three of the people who really wanted
to be identified on Twitter, he said that
Biz would identify one of them.
Ronny the Limo Driver won.
There's a value to identity.
There's a value to verification.
There's a value to having your name out there.
So, I think we've gotta find ways in which
we encourage identity.
We encourage that.
We reward it rather than instead, play Whack-a-Mole
with the fake ones.
I also think that we have to find more reasons
why identity is useful online.
And there's danger here, too.
If governments had to issue internet licenses,
that's bad for everybody.
And it's not good.
We don't want a single verified identity,
because governments will then require you
to use it.
And there goes the internet.
So, there's a role to identity that, I think,
you have to be able to play with.
Then the other side of that is--I say in the
book--that I pretty much control my identity,
but you control my reputation.
When you leave this room, you can, "Oh, that
guy's a bozo.
He talks too fast.
He thinks he's funny.
I wish he wouldn't talk about his penis."
Whatever.
[audience chuckles]
And you can tell the world that.
And that's my reputation.
So, you control my reputation.
I control my identity.
That's too simplistic.
That's not quite right, but there's a variance
there.
So there are questions of authority and certification
and trust and other things where I'm sure
you, in your algorithmic wisdom, will find
ways to help people determine these things
through scenes like reputation that will or
will not be tied to identity that become really
interesting.
I think we're gonna get a lot more nuanced
about identity just as Facebook finally got
more nuanced than "like" or "ignore."
I think identity has to become far more nuanced
and it's very difficult.
All right.
Heading toward the end.
I talk in the book about open businesses and
how to run businesses openly.
And you do that very well to an extent and
don't to an extent.
I don't think that's necessarily that interesting.
I talk about a company called--for you because
you're you, it is to others I hope--a company
called Local Motors that is designing cars
in public.
There's still a CEO that's in charge of the
company, but they have an open design competition
for the cars and a kid at Pasadena won 20
thousand dollars designing the first one.
And then they did the individual parts--the
little elements of the car.
And somebody designed a tail light lens that
the community fell in love with.
And the CEO, who's still responsible for putting
out a safe car and an economically viable
car, said to the community, "OK.
It's beautiful, but if I tool up to make this
custom part, it's gonna add a thousand bucks
to the price of every car.
Do you still want it?"
And they rose as one and said, "Never mind."
[laughter]
And they went looking for alternate parts.
They settled on a 75 dollar Honda tail light
lens that I would never recognize.
What fascinates me about that is here's a
company--.
You look at the auto industry, it is secret
to the extreme.
Literally, they cloak the cars until they
finally take the cloak off and we all yawn.
Well, here's a place where they share the
entire process.
They share the specs of the car so that people
can make products for them, can make the tail
light lenses.
That's really hard for them to do, but they
get great benefit out of it by running the
company openly.
And in this case, here were the customers
sharing in design and economic decisions about
the product.
I think that's remarkable that they were given
the trust and the opportunity to do so.
So, there's other examples like that.
I think we have new companies like Kickstarter,
where you even use your customer’s capital
to start the product.
That's fascinating.
All kinds of views of open companies, but
I'll skip over that.
I did a lot of discussion, some discussion
as well about open government and what that
really should mean.
And it's not just about transparency.
It's not just about "gotcha."
It's also about collaboration.
It's also about moving past.
And I think we're gonna go to a--.
We'll potentially go to a world where we start
to question even the notion of a nation.
I think that's what we're seeing in Occupy
Wall Street and the Arab Spring and Iceland
coming back from its economic disaster by
rewriting their constitution using Facebook.
Get Google+ on that.
It might be better.
And so on.
So, I think when government starts to change,
the notion of a nation and society start to
change.
And I go through that as well.
And I want to skip finally to this one point
that I think is the most important in my mind
and that I wanna recruit you on.
Is I end the book with a call to defend the
principles of openness in society and the
net.
And my argument is that companies cannot be
in the position to secure the openness of
the net.
The one company that's in the best position
to do it is this one.
And in China, in my personal view, you were
on the wrong side.
Then, you were on the right side.
You defended it to the end, your principles,
and I salute you for that as a company.
Verizon, on the other hand, the net neutrality
was different on the wireless and wired net--as
I've called it online "the Internet and the
Schminternet"--which, by the way, is not an
Eric Schmidt joke.
It's a Yiddish joke.
Just to be clear here.
I don't think that was a very good move on
Google's part.
Well, but you're a company and you're now
tied with these devils called phone companies.
And you gotta do things companies do and I
understand that.
I don't like it and probably some of you don't
like it, either.
But that means you are in no position to be
the defender of the net.
And neither do you want to be.
As Eric Schmidt has said, "You don't have
diplomats, except for Dave Drummond.
You don't have police forces and laws.
So, you're not in a position to be the defender
of the net and if you aren't, no company is.
Governments.
Well, I went to the e-G8 conference in Paris
where I had the audacity to challenge Sarkozy
and asked him to take a Hippocratic Oath for
the net--first do no harm.
He dismissed it.
"Ah, you call it harm if I protect your children
and your copyright and your privacy?
It's no harm.
Be harder on me."
So I said, "Well, it could be harm.
It depends on how you do it.
Depends on who does it."
I don't trust government to have sovereignty
over the net.
Have you all read John Perry Barlow's wonderful
"Declaration of Independence from Cyberspace?"
Has anyone read that?
Oh, you've gotta do it.
It's brilliant.
It's over the top as hell.
Google it, pardon me, when you leave.
I'm serious.
And do dramatic readings of it.
It's magnificent.
"People of the future, you have no sovereignty
in this land where we live, this land of the
mind."
It's wonderful.
>>MALE #2: Reread Giants?
>>Jeff Jarvis: Reread Giants of Steel and
yeah.
It's just brilliant.
He's a little embarrassed about being so over
the top, but I try to get him to do a dramatic
reading on Twig once and he wouldn't.
It's wonderful.
So, I came along and I thought, "Well, what
do we need?
Do we need a constitution for the net?"
No.
Because I don't ever want it to be codified
in that way.
Do we need a Bill of Rights for the net?
Well, who enforces it?
Who says what it is?
And I came to believe that what we need is
a discussion--not a set--but a discussion
of the principles of the public society and
an open net.
And I put forward some of mine.
They're wrong.
They're not right.
But I had to volunteer something.
I don't think we'll ever get to a single set,
but if we have the conversation, I think we
will start to discern principles that hold
us together so that when a government does
something bad, we can point to this and say,
"You violated that."
And also so we can give companies cover, so
that at some point when Google's in a difficult
position with China or Verizon, they could
say, "Well, the people of the net really are
gonna raise a ruckus 'cause we know that."
But we, the people of the net, haven't done
this.
Sarkozy brought together what he thought was
the internet.
Larry Lessig from Harvard said, "The future
of the internet is not here because they didn't
know how to get invited.
And you didn't know how to invite them."
But he thought he brought together the world
of the net.
Why did we go to his table?
Why shouldn't we invite him to our table,
us, the citizens of the net?
So, will companies defend the openness of
the net?
No.
Will governments do so?
Most, in fact, defended against some governments.
Who will defend the openness of the net?
We, the people of the net, must.
And I think we have to start by not just thinking
like hackers and hacking around these obstacles.
We have to start deciding what these principles
are because we are, in fact and indeed, building
a new society.
So, here's my list.
And it is an imperfect list and raw list,
but it's the discussion that I want.
First, that we have a right to connect.
Not necessarily in the Finnish sense of everyone
being online through law, but certainly in
a sense that if Mubarak shuts you off from
the net, he has violated your human rights.
We have a right to speak.
We have a right to act and assemble.
There is an ethic of publicness.
There is an ethic of privacy that we should
be following.
What's public is a public good.
And this I say after watching Google and it's
Verpixelungsrecht enabled people to blur their
homes in Google+.
Well, there's a problem there that Google
was taking pictures from the public street
of a public view.
And if Google can be told not to do that,
then perhaps journalists and citizens can
be told not to.
And whenever you limit the public sphere,
you're robbing from the public.
Our governments and our institutions, including
companies, should be moving toward transparency
by default and secrecy by necessity.
We operate the other way today.
Two more.
Every bit is created equal and it if one bit
is discriminated against, whether that's by
Comcast telling you not to watch this movie
versus that one, whether that's China saying
you can't search on Falun Gong, whether that's
Mubarak shutting off the internet, whether
that's Australia filtering all the content.
If one bit is free, than none is free.
None is presumed to be free.
So, all bits must be free.
That's the essence of net neutrality, I think.
And finally, the architecture of the net must
remain distributed and open because that's
what it is.
No one can have sovereignty over the net.
That's what makes the net the net.
And indeed, as we start to see society in
various ways mimic this architecture of the
net, I think we have to treat that architecture
as something more holy, to hold up.
So, these are the things that I hope that
we defend.
And what I would like to see for the likes
of Google is a defense of publicness, a defense
of openness.
Not just from a defensive position, but from
an offensive position.
Or say, that these things are good for society.
These are things that we all need.
These are things that you enable and that
we believe in.
And if we don't do that, then it'll be taken
over by bad governments and bad companies
and bad people and spammers--over Matt Cutts'
dead body.
I always tell everybody in the world that
you would think, given Matt's job, he would
be the meanest son of a bitch you know.
And here, he's one of the nicest guys on Earth
and that always amazes me about Matt.
Or maybe I just see that public face.
Maybe he is a mean son of a bitch behind that.
I doubt that.
[laughter]
>>Female Presenter: He's like that all the
time.
>>MALE #3: He shows up in different circles.
>>Jeff Jarvis: Yeah.
[Jeff Jarvis laughs]
So, that's what I wanted to say.
I wanted to talk about this with all of you
and get your pushbacks and get where you are
and what you're thinking about all this.
As always, I salute you.
You do wonderful things.
I'm glad you exist.
And we couldn't live without you.
But we might have to if the net doesn't stay
open, if what you do gets restricted too much,
if it gets restricted in one country versus
another country.
That's real danger out there.
We might have to if good, well-meaning people
with well-meaning regulation go overboard
and restrict the net so much to the fear of
the worst case that you can't build the best
case anymore.
So, I hope that you stay open to this and
that you as individuals and companies fight
for publicness.
So, that's what I wanted to say.
Let's talk.
[applause]
Let us not--.
Good, OK.
There's always that embarrassing moment where
no one will do it.
I'll do it.
I'm happy to, if you don't mind.
Is it all right?
You know what?
Let me just switch mics 'cause I think this
one is wonky.
Can I switch mics?
OK.
[Jeff Jarvis whistles into mic]
>>MALE #4: I know the other one is good.
>>Jeff Jarvis: The other one's good?
>>MALE #4: The other one's not good.
>>Jeff Jarvis: Oh, I see.
You're a freaking technology company.
>>MALE #5: We don't make mics.
>>Jeff Jarvis: I know, you're not hardware.
[laughter]
Is it on?
>>MALE #6: Is this--?
>>Jeff Jarvis: It works.
>>MALE #6: So, you seem to be conflating two
things, where you say that--.
Well, you say net neutrality is an aspect
of publicness, but it actually seems to me
like that's an aspect of privateness 'cause
I have the right to not have my ISP inspect
my packets, discriminate against this or that
behavior.
And you're saying, and I think we all agree,
with net neutrality and you seem to argue
that privacy in general is misguided--.
>>Jeff Jarvis: I know, they suck.
>>MALE #6: And you sell public.
[laughter]
>>Jeff Jarvis: Fair point.
And when someone at Google says you conflate
things, you run for the hills and get nervous.
Out of respect I say that.
Yeah, I think you're right.
I think you're right.
[laughter]
But I think it's both.
As I said at the beginning, privacy and publicness
are not binary.
They are not opposite.
It is a continuum.
If you enable one, you enable both.
So, it's about control.
Now, Mark Zuckerberg's definition of privacy
was really about control of your information.
I think it's an inadequate definition, except
I first bought it at first.
But I think in this case, it's about who controls
the bits.
And end to end architecture, you at the end,
should control it either way.
>>MALE #6: But if I should control by bits,
I should presumably control my cookies or
"do not track" as well.
I should control my personal information from
sharing on a social network as well, right?
>>Jeff Jarvis: Are you against that?
>>MALE #6: Am I against that?
No.
I think "do not track" makes sense, but you
seem to.
>>Jeff Jarvis: OK.
I was talking about that.
Do not track makes sense.
Why does it make sense?
>>MALE #6: I think the same principle you
had said where I could actually control my
bits from the ISP.
Why should that be different?
That privacy principle that I'm applying to
my data that the ISP is inspecting should
presumably apply to my data at the website,
then the results are inspected.
>>Jeff Jarvis: But it's not just about inspecting.
It's also about restricting.
That's what net neutrality is really about,
is someone's gonna restrict your bits--.
Juggle them.
Now we'll get confused which one is which.
You hold on to that one.
This is the good one.
Hello.
Oh, the voice of God.
All right.
So, this is one of those cases--.
What?
>>MALE #6: You were better off down there.
>>Jeff Jarvis: All right.
I was trying to be Oprah.
>>MALE #7: Your bits are being filtered.
[laughter]
>>Jeff Jarvis: Oprah Habermas.
OK.
So now I gotta think about this.
Yes, there's a control, but I don't necessarily
buy that net neutrality is the same as privacy.
I think they're both issues of control.
They're different issues of control.
The first issue of privacy that you have is
that it's in your head.
And if it doesn't go out of your head, than
that's the most secure place you have.
Then you choose to share something.
Now, the problem we have with the discussion
of privacy is we've gotten to the point, I
think I said earlier, where people think that
the internet is a vault where you store things.
It's a really shitty vault.
You shouldn't put things on the internet if
you want the world not to know this.
Right?
>>MALE #6: You're talking about Eric Schmidt.
>>Jeff Jarvis: Well, yeah, I know.
And, but I also defend him in the book that
the 21 joke was a joke.
But yeah.
I tend to believe that at some point or another,
if I tell Chris something, I have handed over
my fate to Chris.
>>MALE #8: Especially Chris.
[audience chuckles]
>>Jeff Jarvis: Yeah.
Especially.
So, I've made that decision.
He has the responsibility now, but I've lost
control over it to that extent.
So, the best control I have is to keep it
here and not tell him.
So, there's a control issue.
But once I've given it up, I've given it up.
Now, let's go to bigger data.
So, the fact that I searched for "flu."
Sergey says if we're forced to erase those
searches too early, then you may not have
the data necessary to see the anomalous events
that would let you predict the next pandemic.
So, was that search for "flu" mine because
I did it?
No.
It became Google's to the extent that I used
you to do it.
It became maybe the public's to an extent.
These are all different, I think.
Hit me back.
I'm not answering your question.
>>MALE #6: I don't wanna dominate the discussion
and I think the mic doesn't work.
So--.
[laughter]
>>Jeff Jarvis: I gotta think about this one.
I'll blog it.
I'll Google+ it.
>>MALE #6: If you put an attack on "do not
track" by saying, "Well, it might be the website's
that have pay walls."
Well, the consumers would rather support websites
by paying than by having their data sold to
the advertisement companies.
I think the market is working and that's--.
>>Jeff Jarvis: Ah, OK.
Well, let the market do it.
Don't regulate it.
There's no reason to legislate that.
>>MALE #6: That's more of a libertarian argument
of the role of regulation which is the difference
here.
>>Jeff Jarvis: I have the opportunity right
now to deprive the sites of cookies.
I could turn them off at a session.
I could turn them off permanently.
I can kill them after a session.
I can use incognito.
I can do all those things today.
All those tools are in my hands today.
Right?
So, why do we need "do not track" on top of
that, except for the fact that "do not call"
was really popular and Congress wants to pass
things that start with "do not" as a result.
I don't think we need "do not track" at all
and I think that, in fact, that's an example
of how we've done a bad job as an industry
of allowing cookies to be demonized.
In some cases, could we misuse them?
Yes.
But in some cases, because we didn't get out
there and say tracking is not all that bad.
All right.
I'll think about this and we'll see it on
Google+.
What's your name, so I can see who it was?
>>MALE #6: What's my name?
>>Jeff Jarvis: Will you say that?
>>MALE #6: What's that?
>>Jeff Jarvis: Can I follow you on Google+?
>>MALE #6: If you can find me.
>>Jeff Jarvis: Oh, there we go.
[laughter]
Who else?
Behind you.
Yeah.
>>MALE #8: Should we even bother?
>>Female Presenter: Yes.
He'll repeat the question.
>>Jeff Jarvis: I'll repeat the questions.
>>MALE #8: So, why are you such a big proponent
of net neutrality if the market forces competition
who can handle that as well?
>>Jeff Jarvis: I believe that the key to net
neutrality is competition, absolutely.
>>MALE #8: Not regulation?
>>Jeff Jarvis: Right.
So, that's the argument.
That's the libertarian argument is that net
neutrality is a form of regulation.
Al Franken said on South by Southwest, he
said, "That's been mischaracterized that all
we're doing is trying to get the internet
to stay as it was."
We're not trying to change the internet.
We're trying to keep the internet the way
it was and not allow people to come in and
create new restrictions that didn't exist
before.
So what we're protecting is the essence of
the pure internet in his argument.
But I still agree with you absolutely that
the real solution here is competition.
The real solution is if you have the shitty
service that restricts things versus the good
service that doesn't, the market, I believe,
will pick the good things.
I like to wander around.
>>MALE #8: So, you're--.
If there was competition and one company decided
to restrict bits, that's OK?
>>Jeff Jarvis: If there were competition.
Tom Evslin, who started--.
Tom Evslin should be a hero to all of us.
He was the guy at AT&T World Net who took
the clock off the internet and put on flat
pricing at 19.99 a month.
He's the guy who made the internet go whoom.
So, we love Tom.
Tom then started a VoIP company, arbitraging
VoIP.
Tom taught me about this and Tom's a libertarian.
And Tom said, "Even so, we probably need temporary
regulation until we have competition."
Where is the competition gonna come from?
Well, your leaders have pushed for the white
areas to be on regulated spectrum--the white
spaces on broadcast.
Wi-Fi on steroids, so called.
Right?
If we had that, if we're truly an unregulated
spectrum, I believe there would be no need
for regulation.
In the meantime, however, we are prisoned.
There are a few companies that treat us like
prisoners--airlines, phone companies, and
cable companies.
Because we are.
And, and what?
>>MALE #8: Facebook.
>>Jeff Jarvis: Ohhh.
[laughter]
He said that.
I didn't.
Nah, I won't go there.
So, yeah.
I think regulation--.
If you wanna view net neutrality as regulation,
not protection--which is fine--then I think
it's a temporary means, yeah.
Yeah?
You gonna get up or try it?
>>MALE #9: This notion of
privacy is an ethic of knowing is really one
of the light bulb moments in your book, that
it's, you can't restrict the flow of data
and if you try to, it's bad.
But you really have to think about what people
do with the data.
And one consequence, you still seem to see
a lot of "gotcha" people out in private data
that is to say symmetry.
It's like, "Oh, let's beat up Clinton having
an affair, even though we're having an affair,
too."
All that kind of stuff.
I mean, how do we get to the point where if
we really wanna take this ethic of knowing
seriously, people are gonna have to stand
up when bad private things are exposed to
people and say, "Hey, you abused your ethic
of knowing.
Therefore, we're not gonna hold him against
that."
As opposed to now, it still seems like there's
too much willingness to glom on to the things
that were improperly exposed from privacy
and not reflexively saying, "Nope.
That wasn't OK."
>>Jeff Jarvis: Right, so an ethic of not using
people's stuff against them, parens, unless
they deserve it, which is the journalistic
exception.
Because that's what we do is use people's
information against them.
>>MALE #9: I mean, do you think we need to
start seeing the press where other people
stand up and say, "Hey," and pointing at basically
calling people on violating that ethic of
knowing, if it really is gonna be something
that really takes over?
>>Jeff Jarvis: Don't forget.
I'm a Utopian and an optimist.
But I hope that's where the norms start to
go.
Yes.
I have a theory of mutually assured humiliation.
I have my embarrassing pictures.
You have your embarrassing pictures.
If you attack me, I attack you, so you don't.
Arms down.
Now, that, I believe, leads to a more tolerant
in society and that to me is the first step
here.
Some would say too tolerant.
Some people said that being nice to gays is
too tolerant, but screw 'em.
So, a society that becomes more open to more
behaviors and less condemning of them is,
by definition, a more tolerant society.
And I think that's where we go with more publicness.
We could go the opposite.
There's no guarantee of any of this.
The technology doesn't determine and guarantee
any of this and it could go the opposite.
The society could find more ways to condemn
more people.
That's what happens.
I start this with an inherent faith in humankind
and think that it's in our interest to have
a better, nicer place to live and be ourselves
and be free to be ourselves.
Cue Sesame Street.
[laughter]
>>MALE #10: So, if you imagine a world where,
I guess, we live in information abundance
and all bits are free, I'm curious what your
thoughts are on teaching people about the
value of data, or about perhaps relative value
of data, where some information could be more
valuable than other information, depending
on the context, depending on the use, depending
on the aggregation.
How do we get people to believe that storing
their data for long periods of time so they
can make use of it, perhaps 20 years down
the road, and do so either personally or in
aggregate through communities is a better
way to go?
>>Jeff Jarvis: This goes to the whole issue
of publicness, whether it's data or other
forms.
I think that you've gotta show--we talked
about this a lot a bit earlier--we've got
to show those benefits.
And it's not a case of us, who believe in
this, having a--most of us--having a marketing
pitch.
It's about anecdotes, case studies, best practices,
real things people do for real reasons and
they benefit from it.
And that's why I tell the prostate stuff because
even in that case, I had great benefit.
And I have no regret about doing what I did.
>>MALE #11: Is it more germane, like day to
day stuff?
>>Jeff Jarvis: They don't see the benefits
yet, so how do you prove the benefits to people,
right?
How do you prove--?
I mean, Gmail proves it to me because I can
now go back and find people.
Gmail could prove it to me.
Certainly, priority inbox proves it to me
because the fact that you, Google, can learn
about that and can--it's a miracle.
It's a freaking miracle, right?
It's great.
That's a demonstration of it.
I think we gotta demonstrate it.
You're also touching--I'm gonna go to another
point, because it just inspires me to do so.
But it's related and not related.
Value.
Where is value encased?
We, in media, think value is encased in content.
I went out to lunch with a former head of
a network news operation a few months ago
and he said, "You know, that damned Google
and Facebook.
They--" and I don't mean to make him sound
like an old fart, but--
[laughter]
"Them youngun's.
They use our steel in media to make their
cars.
And Mark Zuckerberg doesn't value our content,"
he said.
And I said, "No, actually, come to think of
it, it's the opposite.
The only content you value is the content
you make 'cause you think that only the stuff
you make is a content 'cause you're the content
person."
Mark and Google see content everywhere and
value content everywhere--value it as data.
And go back to signals, that the value is
in the relationships in the data about them.
Content is a valuable tool to get there, but
all the value is not encased in the content.
So, this is why we have this discussion about
pay walls now.
And this is why we have this idea of ownership.
And we go back to this idea of owning my data.
Well, if you take that from me, it's just
wrong of you to do that.
Well, but you can get the value.
We're not showing that.
And well, you know what?
It's actually not that valuable.
If you don't do, OK, fine.
Others are gonna do it and learn.
So, we've gotta get past this notion of where
the value is encased I think.
And the only way we're gonna do it, I think,
is by demonstration.
>>Female Presenter: Maybe one more question?
>>Jeff Jarvis: OK.
Yeah, sure.
>>MALE #11: I'm struck by--
>>Jeff Jarvis: I'm happy to stay and talk
as long as everybody wants.
I've got a red-eye tonight.
>>MALE #11: OK.
I'm struck by the potential to use the--.
A lot of medical studies, they go look for
control groups.
That means they have to find them.
If you had all the medical records for everybody
in the country, you wouldn't have to recruit
a control group.
>>Jeff Jarvis: Oh, that's interesting.
I haven't thought about that.
That's new ammunition.
Because you know the control circumstances.
>>MALE #11: Yeah.
And if you actually allow people--.
If people were--.
I know a guy who publishes his test results.
>>Jeff Jarvis: Right.
>>MALE #11: OK.
Imagine people that did that, that would just
considered to be a normal thing to do.
And to do the same thing preventable.
And also, to go to a website and tell them
a whole bunch of other things about you and
say, "OK.
Medical researchers are, some guy with a degree
in statistics who wakes up at one in the morning
and has an idea.
He gets on and just goes for it."
The number of people who could do medical
research would be--
>>Jeff Jarvis: Staggering.
>>MALE #11: Would be an order of magnitude
of more or larger.
>>Jeff Jarvis: Right.
So, how do we get their society?
Well, I think we gotta talk about the value
of publicness, even to that extent.
And that's gonna freak people out.
It's gonna really freak people out.
But why?
Again, one, job.
You legislate that.
Two, you regulate it.
Two, insurance.
Obama care took away--let's hope it stays--pre-existing
conditions.
But three, the hardest one, is stigmas.
Look what women have done with breast cancer.
And there was a column I think today in the
Times or somewhere saying we've gone overboard.
The Washington Post.
I don't think so.
That's what I'm trying to do with prostate.
Other people don't.
What are you trying to do?
You're trying to take away a stigma.
You're trying to make it OK to talk about
this so that people can get data and get information.
We're a long way from that.
>>MALE #11: Right.
>>Jeff Jarvis: Part of the fear is--.
My concern in being so public is I don't wanna
drag my family into my glass house.
By telling you about my conditions, I have
revealed my children's DNA.
Astrid--.
My son went to Esther Dyson, who's published
her genome.
She said, "Get over it, Jeff.
Everybody gets prostate cancer.
It's OK."
A very Esther scientific view.
But yes, we've gotta get to that point, but
as a society, we're so far away from it and
we're going in the wrong direction.
So, it's a great example and a great case
of proving the value to you and society of
being open.
How do you think we get there?
>>MALE #11: Appeal to disease interest groups,
so that the members of the diseased's families
put their stuff up along with--.
And go to other interest groups, like, "We'll
do it for you if you do it for us.
You can use us for controls.
We can use you for controls."
>>Jeff Jarvis: '23andme', um,not that, well,
23andme's part of that.
PatientsLikeMe, you know site, right?
I think is pretty amazing and it's under anonymity,
which is OK, but people get to share their
dosages and side effects and so on and so
forth and it has real value.
A friend of mine's wife has MS and he said
that this has been absolutely invaluable to
her because you can see the dosages of where
it goes.
For my many conditions, I would love to have
that kind of community.
I went to pages like me.
They only started with about a dozen very
serious disorders.
They've now opened up to a lot.
But if I go in for thyroid cancer, there's
like one other person.
And he's taking my drug, so I don’t have
any critical mass of data.
>>MALE #11: Disease side effects are greatly
under reported because I know lots of people
have gotten a prescription, they've tried
it.
They felt funny.
They never told their doctor they stopped
using it.
But if everyone who had ever used that disease
had said so, you can go find all these things
and say, "Oh, look."
>>Jeff Jarvis: I'm gonna sound like my parents
down in Sun City Central, Florida, going through
what they call the organ recital here.
The condition I got off of 9/11 is atrial
fibrillation, irregular heartbeat.
And you get--.
I'm under the care of a magnificently named
drug called Rythmol.
It gives me rhythm.
Knock on wood it works.
People have onsets of a-fib and it's rather
mysterious why they do.
And my simple wish for this is if every fib
patient felt free to describe their days,
48 hours, what they ate, what they did, what
they thought, before an onset,
I gotta believe that there's some correlations
to be found.
And not doing that hurts every one of those
people and increases our costs and does all
these bad things.
But we're in a mode of going in the opposite
direction not only in privacy, but also on
information.
The decision made by the government panel
last week on prostate PSA testing was that
statistically, and I'm speaking to the wrong
group here about statistics, statistically
it doesn't save lives.
Well, as a cohort, perhaps.
But as an individual, it gave me information.
Now, perhaps I shouldn't have had the operation
because you can't tell the difference between
slow moving and fast moving prostate cancer.
Well, until they can't figure that out, I'm
gambling.
Don't wanna gamble with the cancer in me.
Put the cancer out of me.
As far as I'm concerned, I would always better
have more information than less.
The use of what I do with that may be flawed.
Maybe I shouldn't have had the operation.
But I had no basis to know and it was my gamble.
What the panel was saying was, "It's the pool's
gamble.
It's a financial gamble."
Well, I hate that.
What that says is that the government is telling
you, "Better to be ignorant."
That is never a good policy.
More information--I gotta believe you believe
this at Google--more information is always
better than less information.
Heads nod.
OK.
So, this is where I say that I think could
Google being in the position it's in, has
to find a way to fight for these kinds of
things, to demonstrate it to people, to argue
for it, to lobby not just to Congress, but
to lobby to the people and start to come up
with pilot groups and you're a platform for
that, and show how it's possible.
And yes, it's gonna be counter-intuitive when
it comes to privacy, but that's good, too.
Because you can show examples of how radical
publicness, of those who are willing, of those
who chose, helped more people.
That's a good thing.
I guess you guys are prompt-like.
I'm happy to stay and talk as long as you
like, but you won't be rude if you leave.
So I guess, how's that?
Anybody else wanna challenge me in any way,
or are you ready to get back to work?
All right.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
[applause]